the delta variant has
very visibly raised the price of stupid
right and
because it's raised the price of stupid
of entrenched stupidity the price of
stupid has gone up as the cost of stupid
and the stupid politics that run along
with that the endurance of the stupidity
of the stupid caucus cost of stupid has
risen who rode the stupid way of hmm
stupid
that's the first thing joe and mika say
to each other when they wake up
yes i hate them terrible people
[Applause]
well
it's been 20 years since 9 11 and you
got to wonder what's it like for the
person who's not 20
do they know enough about what happened
that day to produce a cogent opinion
well once you look at the latest campus
reform student on the street interview
the answer might be
god help us
did you learn a lot about 9 11 growing
up in the classroom
uh not in the classroom but on my own i
like kind of did my own little like
research thing no i did not um i'd say
we learned a moderate amount um i mean
they showed us like the videos like the
basics
i didn't learn super specifics about it
like i had like a whole unit where it
was like two months worth of learning
about it which was a little strange yeah
definitely my family is bengali so we're
all muslim so it was a very like it's
something we were very conscious of um
well that was as comforting as someone
looking at their watch during a
funeral but hey they're young we're all
kind of silly back then but maybe given
the chance what would they want people
to learn about 911
when talking about 911 what do you think
we should avoid i think we should like
avoid a lot of more gruesome facts avoid
talking about its roots in islam because
that
that was a like an
extremist group um i think that um the 9
11 attacks should be taught in a way
that doesn't really target like more
like who did it but like
more like how we can like move forward
and like different like healing
processes that we can go through to like
make everything like you know good again
so you don't think it's important to
know who is responsible i do think it's
important to know who's responsible that
but i also think it should be noted that
like their religion is not the only
thing avoiding kind of placing blame
because when you get to the more like
specific
factors that were at play you know it
kind of opens the opportunity for things
like islamophobia and ideas of american
exceptionalism ugh gross
look it's unfair to say these kids are
representative of a population as a
whole but what are they representative
of how about an educational system
that's more about indoctrination than
instruction one that pushes
anti-american bile spewing from
miserable passive aggressive physically
unattractive perpetually wrong
professors whose misdirected anger
damage impressionable minds
thanks to these marxist think tanks we
call universities we have a few
generations who know less about this
country than i do about dunking a
basketball
and somehow exceptionalism is easier to
condemn than terrorism
there's a recent video that came out
from the virginia department of
education that showcased an american
university lecturer and she basically
said that when talking about 9 11 we
should avoid talking about american
exceptionalism would you agree with that
yeah for sure
we definitely should because we don't
need we don't need more nationalism in
this country we need more
like
healthcare i don't know i think they
should focus on america's faults not
like
how amazing we are and how we need to be
superior because we're not in terms of
um
propagating this idea that our nation is
the best no matter what um
i would agree that that should be
avoided i don't think we should be
talking about like the greatness of the
country i definitely don't agree that
america is the best country on the earth
i think that we still need a lot of like
fixing i think it's a dangerous mindset
to to teach
young people that because i think that's
the reason why
a lot of people grow up to be kind of
extremists and like really nationalistic
oh i hope stupidity is not contagious
why would someone their age think this
country is exceptional
they got to the party late the house is
crowded they don't know these new people
who just keep strolling in fights are
breaking out the keg is almost empty and
the authorities are on their way to shut
it down
they arrived as this once great party
started winding down
and sadly to them something horrible
perpetrated against us
is just another opportunity to talk
about how bad we are
so unlike jessie's hair
history is a
malleable thing
like that word
who teaches it and how they teach it can
determine how your kid interprets the
world and if they're too young and
fearful to call bs
it's easy to be brainwashed just
recently at work for less cops will make
us safer
so what would i tell them right now i
was in new york city when it happened it
was as surreal as it was devastating
because it's the first time you felt
engulfed in horror well second if you
were married
you're in the heart of evil it's not a
movie it's not something you can't walk
out of because it sucks
and you're in it and it changes you
forever the same way a person is changed
forever if they are a victim of a
violent crime you can't have these baby
thoughts about silly things you can't
just shrug it off as something we
deserve because we're so mean and
powerful
that day was something else and that
something else is called evil
sadly that's forgotten as many now
occupy their brains with
like gender pronouns and self-obsessed
grievance but i'm pretty sure if you
were on the 95th floor of a burning
building and the firemen rescuing you
called you the wrong pronoun
you'd let it slide
some events in life have a way of
putting things in perspective the
difference between what's important and
what's trivial
911 was one of those events but this 20
year conflict for some has been backpage
news including politicians and media
not as interesting as britney
kaepernick or black lives matter
there's too much stuff to think about
and a lot of it really doesn't require
thinking at all just feeling angry and
looking important and saying what you're
told to say
we've insulated the country successfully
from our conflicts but by insulating
them they now have no visceral response
to this moment this event that affects
millions of people
it's so good here people don't even know
it's good we assign false bravery to the
loudest voices who can cry the hardest
who can claim the most victimhood
this relates to 9 11. on that day almost
20 years ago we were reminded that we
were americans not blacks whites gays
trans non-binary woodland creatures
we didn't proclaim our separate
categories we were americans too bad it
took 3 000 innocent souls violently
snatched from us to remind us of that
that's not tribalism or nationalism it's
understanding what you share with each
other that you were attacked for being
you
fact is in 2001 we were americans but in
20 years time we've been coerced by a
prophet seeking media to reject that you
could argue these entities have done
more psychological damage to this
country than any outside enemy creating
a whole industry off of hating america
because inciting wars between each other
means profits for companies power for
activists and a distraction from real
evil
on the 20th anniversary of 9 11
we call people who don't want a vaccine
terrorists
fact is as long as we are at each
other's throats who needs terrorists
al-qaeda did 9 11.
the rest is a self-inflicted gunshot
wound as a result of friendly
let's fire
tonight's guest
if she had it her way she'd be
co-hosting the four
america's newsroom co-anchor and the
five co-host jade a burrito
there you go he can kill a man 30
different ways 29 of them with his
leather pants retired green beret master
sergeant hopes the hollywood weapons on
the outdoor title jury shepard
she is the target market for zoloft
gummies fox news contributor cat tim
when asked what tyrus does for a living
his opponent said beats me
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television tribute
all right
uh terry yes sir like me you are a hero
after 9 11 i went on and did some things
for my country uh editing maxim
uh what did you do after 9 11.
so yeah so i've been out of the
perfect tee up
so i've been out for four and a half
years i got out from active duty i've
been almost nine i went to classical
theater school circle in the square i
was a working actor in manhattan and we
got attacked so i thought
what do i do next so i re-enlisted in
the national guard green braze and i was
october 2001 and i retired in october
2016.
so that's what i did and i i remember
thinking to myself okay we're at war
what do i do
i'm not telling people
that that's what you have to do that's
what was the right decision for me it
created my career in one way but also
opened up other opportunities and i
remember after i got back from the first
deployment after 9 11 my mom and my mom
said to me she goes i haven't seen you
look this happy in a long time and i go
well i'm around the guys i love and so
that's what i did i i actually am not
interested i've never been interested in
hearing how people felt
during 9 11. i don't really care what
you were doing when it happened
what did you frickin do afterwards how
did you change yourself did you did you
get smarter were you kinder
did you stop voting for people who are
working for your demise you know did you
pay attention and i think a lot of
people
right off the bat they did but then they
sort of stopped and i want to say
something else too about the young
people we just saw a clip of really
really
not very smart and soft shell crab human
beings
there's a whole other side of our
country that's not that right it's the
young young the young studs that i saw
coming in that would put on their body
armor and go down the road knowing they
were going to get hit these 19 year old
kids and when we just lost the 13
recently everybody was like oh they're
so young right who did you think were
fighting your wars yeah did you think it
was joe biden or bernie sanders or even
donald trump no it's young people it's
young people doing it and so
hard times make hard men
hard men make good times good times make
soft men and we are now on the stage of
soft men make hard times so that's
what's coming
you know uh that's amazing
um
but i think
i think the take-home message here and
the real tragedy insult no i'm gonna
tell you the real tragedy is that 911
killed terry's acting career
think about dana think of all the movies
we missed
he was a stage actor yes i i really feel
it was a mercy killing it was a mercy
killing
first of all he's on tv i love you
hate you not a fan of you anymore and
you
i got nothing to say you're terrible
people but dana's the best
shame on you
fair so dana like like me you're a hero
i mean your life changed because you
ended up coming to dc correct yeah my
life yeah i look back on this day it's
been a lot of reflections this week and
i think that the fact that we are
remembering and commemorating this day
this 20 years it feels like it's a
milestone and it is something where you
have some people like i read in the
paper they're like we just got to move
on yeah we don't need to have these
memorials and then i've been watching
some of the documentaries that have been
done and i'm like look at what the
people went through yeah and imagine
suggesting that the united states no
longer needs needs to teach what
happened at pearl harbor right or what
happened to martin luther king jr
or what happened to jfk
or what happened to george floyd
right would anybody suggest that you
shouldn't do that but this one this one
they wanted to let go because they don't
want to think america is exceptional
anymore or that america is a bit like
america is the victim here they don't
want to hear that either because we're
the bad guy all those other all those
other things you mentioned you could
argue
is america's fault right
absolutely you could and they do yeah
and i think that um condi rice has a
piece in the wall street journal in
which she says if we don't continue to
do this if we don't live up to never
forget we are doomed to repeat it which
is um not as eloquent a way of saying
what he what terry ended with
because well he's an actor and i i would
say that it is really important to think
about
all those young people that we saw on on
the video i could watch that all day
yeah um but you think about the young
people that died outside the kabul
airport
and and they were signing up to serve
their country in order to make sure that
they could say whatever they wanted yeah
yeah and i don't even i don't i don't
want to bang on these uh these kids too
much because you know they're walking
down the streets and they're not
thinking about like all men on the
street stuff is like almost kind of like
these people are not prepared if you ask
me anything on the street there's a 50
chance i'm on on a substance
and whatever comes out of my mouth is
going to just feel dumb oh yeah no i'll
be brilliant yeah i'll be brilliant
right much like your acting career
um so this is what's going to be on the
rest of the night now yeah no you know
that you gave me the one line that i did
a beat to the ground thank you for your
service you chose by the way gutfeld
you're welcome for your freedom yes
to mock me
listen you chose not to wear leather
pants you did this to yourself if you
had worn leather pants i would have been
much nicer oh i'm sure you would have
better they're chaps or something but i
hate all of them i hate all of them you
know um no chaps here no
yeah cat cat when you in on september 11
2001 you were 36.
[Laughter]
actually you were um what are you 11 or
12. i was 12. right yeah so okay
as a 12 year old what was that like
well it was as a 12 year old i was at
school were you a fat kid no
gosh
i thank you though because that would
have been very relevant to my experience
of what 9 11 was like for me yes um
and
it was nobody would like tell us what
happened like nobody would tell us we
were in a school we didn't have like tvs
in in the school or anything like that
we didn't have like internet phones or
anything like
amish saint mary's catholic school in
mount clemons
yeah and so i had to wait till i got
home
and you know was just watching the tv
and i it's the first time i remember you
know asking my parents about stuff that
they didn't really have the answers to
because they were just as shocked and
confused as i was right yeah it was when
the adults were powerless yep yeah all
right last word tyrus i'm kind of
curious what you were doing 20 years ago
but i want to know what you're thinking
now well i'm i'm thinking that i'm glad
he hates you a little more than me so
um that's getaway time yes uh you know i
was in louisville texas with uh my dear
friend martin simmons who's not with us
anymore we were we were just coming off
of arena football and i just got signed
my first agent and i had to try out with
the dallas cowboys and i was trying to
figure out the cowboys the bills and i
had a toronto deal so i had all these
real important things so i we went to
the club that night that we partied get
up in the morning and we see the planes
go in the building and we thought it was
a tv show i kept switching the channels
still didn't still resonate like what
just happened
and then for me although i didn't go
into acting then but it was at that
moment that i realized that like my
priorities in life are completely
because i'm the most important thing in
the world right now and i because all i
care about is my sports and seeing what
was going on that's when i started
getting into looking into politics and
looking into things right so for me it
really
caused me to grow up a little more
mentally
and see what we could do you know
because we were helping getting supplies
on that we wanted to go down there but
they started stopping people because so
many people volunteered to go to new
york and dig up stuff and we were
willing to
guys we're working and training with
we're big strong guys like hey we can go
help and we're being stopped but we
found things to send supplies down there
yeah did you want to say something dana
i was going to say for those for young
people today the one thing they didn't
get to experience on 9 11 that we did
was everyone coming together yes and
that feeling and that ability and i
think that we all kind of miss that we
long for it and we keep thinking
something's going to happen to bring us
back to that moment it should have been
coveted it could have been you know all
right which we're going to talk about in
the next block still ahead the grand
finale of my epic donald trump interview
and up next biden says
uh but fine
fine
can you read that i don't even know what
that says
biden says heat is vaccine order but not
if you jump this head who puts heed
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else